ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
In a previous episode,
we went over how logs are
aggregated across all of GCP
and how to navigate them.
In this episode, we'll
talk about error reporting,
a Google Cloud tool available
to help you better capture
errors, categorize them,
and manage their lifecycle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Application level errors happen,
sometimes even in production.
And the last thing
you want is crawling
through your logs to find
the relevant information.
Instead, cloud log's reporting
aggregates and displays errors
produced in your
running Cloud Services.
It automatically groups together
error and critical level errors
from your application
into groups
and can notify you if a
new error group appears.
This works across many languages
and is supported out-of-the-box
by Cloud Functions, App Engine,
Cloud Run, Compute Engine,
and GKE.
Any of your
application errors can
be surfaced using
error reporting,
provided that they
use basic formatting
or that they simply call
the error reporting API.
Errors are grouped
and de-duplicated
by analyzing their stack
traces, so you only
see one entry per error type.
Each error entry
provides a summary
that helps you determine
when the application started
to produce the error,
how often it occurred,
and how recently it occurred.
One thing I really
like is the ability
to set a resolution
status for each error.
It defaults to open and can be
set to acknowledged, resolved,
or simply muted.
Errors can also be linked to an
issue in a bug tracking system.
This is really powerful,
and thankfully you
do not need to stare at
the console in search
of potential errors.
Instead, you can be
notified in real time
via email, or my favorite, via
the Google Cloud mobile app.
But maybe the most
important thing
about cloud error
reporting is that it
requires zero setup for
all of Google Cloud's
serverless products.
And it's really just
a few simple steps
for other products.
If you are a developer and
if restarting or redeploying
your application just
incorporate some new logging
statements sounds
painful, then be
sure to keep your eyes
open for an upcoming
episode for a truly unique
solution to this problem using
debug log points.
In a future episode,
we'll also talk
about tools available to
help you better understand
the problem that led
to any of those errors
and, most importantly,
how to fix them.
If you liked this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to more
Google Cloud Essentials videos.